divya received the following problem a
particle moves in a straight line with
velocity V of T is equal to the square
root of 3 t minus 1 m/s where T is time
in seconds at T equals 2 the particles
distance from the starting point was 8
meters in the positive direction
what is the particles position at T
equals 7 seconds which expression should
Divya use to solve the problem so pause
this video and have a go at it alright
now let's do this together so we want to
know the particles position at T is
equal to 7 so what we could do they tell
us what our position is at T equals 2 so
what the position at T equals 7 would be
your position at T equals 2 plus your
change in position from T equals to 2 T
is equal to 7 and there's another word
for this you could also call this your
displacement from T equals to 2 T equals
7 and we know how to think about
displacement velocity is your rate of
change of displacement and so if you
want to figure out your displacement
you're between two times you would
integrate the velocity function so this
is going to be the integral from T
equals to 2 T equals 7 of our velocity
function V of T DT this would be our
displacement from time to 2 times 7 so
if they said what is our change in
position from time to 2 times 7 it would
be just this expression but they want to
they want us to figure out or they want
Divya to figure out what is the
particles position at T equals 7 seconds
so what you would want to do is your
position at T equals 2 and we know at
our position at T equals 2 is it was 8
meters in the positive direction so we
could just call that positive 8 meters
so it's going to be 8 plus your change
in position which is going to be your
displacement and let's see we can see
this choice right over there and that's
what we would pick this first option V
of 7 that just gives us our
velocity at time seven or at exactly at
seven seconds or another way our rate of
change of displacement at seven seconds
so that's not what we want this one
right over here you have your position
at T equals two but then you have your
change in position from T equals zero to
T equals seven so this doesn't seem this
isn't right and this is your position at
time two plus your V Prime the
derivative of velocity is the
acceleration plus your acceleration at
time seven so that's definitely not
going to give you your the particles
position so we like that second choice